look at the most successful people in
the world I know very few them that
haven't had a major failure the
investing business you can learn by
reading you know read everything Warren
Buffett's ever written watch every
YouTube video he's ever appeared in
that's a great way to learn about
investing to be a successful investor
you have to be able to avoid some
natural human tendencies to follow the
herd need motivation
he's Bill Ackman and here's my take on
his top ten roses success enjoy
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one overcome adversity I don't know
they're very few people you look at the
most successful people in the world I
know very few then that haven't had a
major failure you know if you read
through the they're not the financially
most successful people if you look read
for the Forbes billionaire list and you
read their stories you know they've had
failed businesses and they've lost
everything and they've hung on the you
know they almost died holding on to the
ledge you know what's his name
the guy on CBS and some of their fires
some redstone redstone so there are lots
of examples of people who had huge
adversity and I think it's how you deal
with adversity that determines your
ultimate success as opposed to how you
deal with success that determines your
ultimate success
rule number two study success the
investing business you can learn by
reading you read everything Warren
Buffett's ever written watch every
youtube video he's ever appeared in
that's a great way to learn about
investing but in fact investing is more
than just the way to really understand
investing is to understand a business
and one of the most important skills you
need as an investor is distinguishing
between a great business a good business
a fair business and a bad business and
one way to get a sense of the quality of
businesses go to work for one so the
recommendation I give to people
graduating from business schools these
days is this is the greatest time in
history to work for a startup lots of
incredibly interesting businesses being
formed
if you can be one of the early employees
you're gonna learn a lot about how our
business works how to make payroll how
to market your product how to design
something and those skills I think are
invaluable first of all you might even
find it really interesting you might
have joined the next Facebook so that's
one thing even if the business fails
you'll learn a ton from that I think
that's the best experience you can get
ultimately to be a good fundamental
investor rule number three invest well
how do you be a successful investor now
I'm assuming that you're not gonna go
into the business of investing I'm
assuming that you're gonna be a doctor
or lawyer you're gonna pursue your
passion but you're gonna have some money
they're gonna save over time and I'm
gonna give you my advice on the topic
it's not necessary defendant advice but
it's what the advice I would give my
sister my grandmother on what she should
do if you were in the same
and avoid investing in start-up
businesses where the prospects are not
very well known because again you don't
need to make a hundred percent a year to
have a fortune you just need to invest
at an attractive return 10-15 percent
over a long period of time your money
grows very significantly so how do you
avoid the riskiest investments I would
my advice would be to invest in public
security invest in listed companies
companies that trade in the stock market
why because those businesses are tend to
be more established they have to meet
certain hurdles before they go public
the stocks are liquid so you can change
your mind if you want to sell if you
invest in a private lemonade stand it's
hard to find someone to take you out of
that investment unless that business
becomes fabulously profitable that's a
piece of advice number one invest in
public companies number two you want to
invest in businesses that you can
understand what I mean by that is there
are lots of businesses that you come in
that you deal with in the course of your
day and your personal life whether it's
a retail store that you know because you
like shopping there or it's a product
your your iPad or that you know you
think it's a great product but you know
you understand how the company makes
money the business is just too
complicated you don't understand how
they make money even if they've had a
great track record I would avoid it a
lot of people thought and wrong was an
incredible business because it appeared
to have a good track record but very few
people understood how they made money it
was good to avoid it another very
important criteria is you want to invest
at a reasonable price it could be a
fabulous business that's done very well
over a long period of time but if you
pay too much for it you're not gonna
earn a very good return the last bit is
that you want to invest in a business
that you could theoretically own forever
the stock market were too close for 10
years you wouldn't be unhappy what do I
mean by that now again if you're gonna
compound your money if at 10 or 15
percent return over forty three year
period of time you really want to
business it you can own forever you
don't want to constantly have to be
shifting from one business to the next
and what of what are businesses that you
can own forever well the very few that
sort of meet that standard may be a good
example is Coca Cola right what's good
about Coca Cola is it's relatively easy
business to understand you understand
how coke makes money right they sell a
formula or syrup to bottlers and to
retail establishments and they make a
profit every time they serve a coca-cola
people going to drunk a lot of Coca Cola
for a very long period of time the
world's population is growing they sell
in almost every country in the world and
each year people drink a little bit more
Coca Cola so it's a pretty easy business
to understand and it's also a business
that I think it's unlikely to be
competed away as a result of technology
or some other new product right it's
been around long enough people have
grown used to the taste you know they
make parents give it to their children
and you can expect that we'll be around
a long period of time rule number four
be direct in my approach in business in
my personal life in a management role is
extreme candor and I think that if you
live that way you know you'll run the
risk of offending various people over
time but you'll have much better
relationships because you know if you
tell people the truth first of all it's
not typical you know a lot of people in
the interest of politeness or fear of
confrontation or it's just uncomfortable
don't speak the truth and that goes for
people on boards you know there are lots
of examples of super talented people
sitting around the room as an
institution is failing think of all the
banks during the crisis where people
were not willing to confront the CEO so
I'm willing to confront the CEO and but
I'm completely candid with him about his
successes and his failures also if you
want to have more confidence checking my
250 for confidence series it's free the
link to join is in the description below
you have to explain why you're the right
person to lead and above all you have to
know your numbers I've always been
passionate some people thought you know
it's a it's more OCD than anything else
the minute you begin to get external in
your life worrying about what other
people think about you right you vote
you've lost all control you and it never
fills you up rule number 5 be confident
investing is about the best investments
are the ones where we are the confident
we're right and everyone else is wrong
ok and you have to in order to be you
know I've been accused recently of being
arrogant among the know I'm gonna
actually ask you that it was called it
was pompous but that's ok
pompous I don't think I'm pompous but
I've been certainly been accused of
being arrogant and there's a difference
between arrogance and confidence yeah
if you're arrogant and investing you're
gonna get killed guide if you're not
confident you'll never make an
investment all right so you have to do a
sufficient amount of work to be
confident enough to have the conviction
do something that's contrarian right we
bought the stock of a a soon to be
bankrupt retailer I'm sorry a shopping
mall company during the financial crisis
at pennies per share you have to be
willing to look silly when you do
something like that general growth
stocks up 90 fold since our original
investment you know on that's we had
confidence maybe people thought was
arrogant to believe that we'd be
successful in turning around rule number
six contribute it weren't invested what
would you be that's a good question I
mean I would do what I do now even if I
weren't compensated for doing it because
I think it's a way for me to make the
biggest contribution that I can make I
mean I look I think about government if
I could if I could effectuate change the
same way I can effectuate change in the
in the private sector but I think I can
have more influence as a private
participant that a public participant
rule number seven deal with criticism
when this guy that I met money manager
named Bob Chapman who I met on a panel
seven years ago we were on a panel
together show cans never spoken to him
since I've never out of email
correspondence I've never seen him since
but in the last 90 days he's been
running the talk show circuit on how I'm
you know either wrong or stupid or
arrogant you know give him quotes to
Vanity Fair it's unfortunate you know I
don't mind criticism but I don't I don't
like reading things that are I don't you
know it's hard to read they for somebody
doesn't know me well to be commenting on
what I'm like as a person I find I find
it difficult but you know whatever I got
it you have to have a thick skin to be
in this business and you know if you end
up in a very public situation you should
expect to have fans and critics and you
know I just try to focus on you know
what my job is and we focus on making
money for our investors and I live my
life rule number eight learn your craft
I went to business school to learn how
to be a good investor
and I learned the first rule of
investing which is you do your due
diligence before you wider than your
money and when I got the HBS I actually
opened the course catalog for the first
time and there wasn't a class on
investing in other classes on accounting
or classes on Finance so I decided I had
to develop my own little self study
program and I wanted to so I opened a
fidelity brokerage account I said this I
had some money I've made in the real
estate brokerage business this was my
tuition in the investment business and
it was about a year of tuition and if I
lost it it was as if I had gone to a
business school for you know two years
but paid for three so I figured it
wasn't like the the inverse of the
Oxford one plus one program but and you
know I the first stock I bought went up
and I said okay I found what I want to
do more involved in that but I I
actually my father who's here he came
with us that's dad over there in the
corner you can ask him whatever
questions you want afterwards he told me
is a really dumb idea to start an
investment fund right out of his in
school and he recommended that I go work
for Michael Steinhardt or George Soros
or one of the other famous ambassadors
at the time but I figured that I knew
enough this is the the perils of youth
but the answer is I was an entrepreneur
and I felt that I wanted to approach
investing my own way as opposed to learn
from someone else and it's one of the
few things you can really learn on your
own you can learn investing by reading
books by reading annual reports by
having a you can have a portfolio and
invest $100 and you can and you can
learn the business unlike many other
businesses which require a lot more rule
number nine don't follow the herd to be
a successful investor you have to be
able to avoid some natural human
tendencies to follow the herd the stock
market's going down every day your
natural tendency used to want to sell
the stock markets actually going up
every day your natural tendencies want
to buy so in bubbles you probably should
be a seller in busts you should probably
be a buyer and you have to have that
kind of a discipline you have to have a
stomach to withstand the volatility the
stock market and rule number ten the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is give opportunities
you known for occasionally hiring people
with some non-traditional financial
backgrounds form a fly-fishermen a
tennis pro someone you met in a taxi so
what actually are you looking for so
most of the people that we have on the
investment team are people with more
conventional backgrounds half the team
worked at Blackstone in either private
equity or Investment Banking a few guys
from Goldman Sachs but I'm a big
believer you know I had internships in
my life and you know if I meet a great
human being you know I want to give some
you know people who didn't go to Harvard
Business School and didn't work at
Goldman Sachs for four years you know
some exposure so I met the beginning of
Pershing I met a guy named Oliver white
who I believe is one of the you know
he's become recognized one on top fly
fishing guides in the world
very smart interesting guy taught me fly
fishing and I said look if you're
interested in business and you want to
intern at you learn something about it
you know come work for me and Oliver
came and spent 18 months with us you're
taking a very outdoorsy guy and you're
putting them in had in which is kind of
an interesting thing he didn't like that
part of it but you learn a ton about
business and then he left he actually
worked a lot on one of our proxy contest
situations in the Ceridian we had a
proxy contest one of the issues was the
the CEO was using the corporate jet to
do a lot of fly fishing junkets so we
were able to track that stuff through
his network of fly fishermen so it was a
useful in the proxy contest anyway
and Oliver left you know to do and I
backed him to buy a fly fishing launch
which the Abaco Lodge and in Abaco in
the Bahamas and it's like you know 20%
on levered return on capital and he's
done an unbelievable job managing in and
we hired a guy named Marius Adamski who
I met on the tennis court super talented
guy went to Wake Forest you know top
tennis player and he you know offered
him a job and he's worked for us for the
last couple of years and he did a lot of
the research on Herbalife and he did a
phenomenal job so I just you know I was
gonna go to business school because he's
gonna he needs more training to come
back into the business but I think it's
a you know a nice thing to offer people
those kind of well I was offered
opportunities like
now I've got a special bonus clip on
making mistakes that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
let's go from just watching the video to
taking action here we go
question number one how can you give
someone an opportunity this week number
two what's the criticism that you need
to deal with better and number three
what three people will you study success
from this month experience is making
mistakes and learning from mistakes and
unfortunately as students you haven't
made many mistakes yet if you've gotten
to Oxford at this point in your career
the biggest risk is you probably haven't
screwed up a lot and so you know the
risk of that is when data comes across
your desk that's inconsistent with your
being successful you're less likely to
pay attention to it than if you've made
a few mistakes so I encourage you to
make some mistakes and actually I've
made plenty of over the course of my
career and I think I've been very
successful over time but it's not been a
straight line up in fact I had if I were
a stock it would look something like
this after business school you know and
then and so the concern is whether this
is coming in fractured but but so far
they you know the overall trend has
generally been positive but now there
are certainly bumps along the way
if you want to learn from some of the
world's most successful investors check
out the video right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I'm in a
know called strike business which is the
best business you can be in and you said
that portfolio balancing is a waste of
time so what are John and Sally